[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar avoiding hurdles and molecular
assay development i am michelle ashton
of labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is interactive and will
include several poll questions
distributed throughout the presentation
your participation is greatly
appreciated
without further ado i'd like to now
welcome our speaker naini nathu
new business development manager
molecular diagnostics
naim you may now begin your presentation
my name is naive nathu i am a business
development manager at thermo fisher
scientific supporting molecular
diagnostics
so for today we'll start with an
introduction
then move to some current challenges in
molecular test development
followed by attributes of improved
enzyme design
methods and enzyme development we'll see
next generation enzymes in action
through some case studies
and end off with quality and
manufacturing capabilities at thermo
fisher scientific that can routinely be
leveraged by our customers
so here's the workflow from a high level
and it has three major phases extraction
amplification and detection
if we start with the extraction we can
see that there's a wide variety of
sample input types and it's critical to
be cognizant of what characteristics and
features come with leveraging a specific
sample input type depending on what your
target is dna and or rna and you're
going to want to pick a sample
extraction method and is curated to that
specific sample input type
if we jump over to detection for a
minute you can see that there's a wide
variety of ways to do that downstream
analysis
but the
meat or the bulk of the conversation
today is going to be around
amplification and this is primarily
broken out into two major subcategories
on the left hand side
we can see the
quantitative side of amplification the
qpcr the rtq-pcr
it is
a real-time analysis that has the
benefits of accuracy speed and
specificity and it measures the load of
your specific target in this particular
instance we've called out infectious
agents it's great for things like target
detection target quantitation and
genotyping
on the flip side of this we have
isothermal amplification or endpoint pcr
this is more of the qualitative side
of amplification
it measures the presence or absence of
your target of interest and in this case
again we've called out let's say
infectious agents it has the benefits of
speed simplicity and ease of detection
and more recently it's become quite
popular in the field of poc or in-field
diagnostics it gives the ability for
that rapid diagnosis of whether your
target is present or absent
so when we talk about
amplification
there's going to be some challenges or
key features or things that you're going
to want to consider along the way
through your assay development so if we
focus on the performance aspect
there are going to be
challenges you may come up against
regarding accuracy or reproducibility or
specificity and or sensitivity
on the other side or on the other hand
you'll have the operational parameters
regarding your assay how easy is it to
access your tests how easy is it to use
your test is it just as simple as
putting your sample in and hitting a
button right and of course the time to
obtaining those results how fast and how
scalable can we get those results from
the time that we start that assay
if we take a step back at the workflow
we can see that it's connected end to
end
and dependent on
whether our target is dna and or rna
embedded within that sample we're going
to want to be cognizant of what are the
features or characteristics of our
sample input type
and based on that we may be able to
identify proactively what sort of
amplification challenges we may come up
against and that's what that middle
column is really highlighting right
depending on our sample input type do we
have a limited number of sample or
amount of sample concentration of our
target within that sample
is there carryover of inhibitors do you
have dna or rna degradation or
potentially long turnaround times right
and based on those different
characteristics
we can select next generation enzymes
that have been built to proactively
address these challenges that you may
face within your assay
so to reiterate if we look at some of
again those current challenges that
we've seen
low test sensitivity
risk of degradation long testing times
and potentially developing more complex
assays that are capable of multiplexing
we're going to want to select next
generation enzymes that have specific
phenotypes to address these challenges
and some of those phenotypes include
processivity improved processivity
speed specificity
accuracy
and thermal stability
so in the following slides we're going
to cover
each of these
key attributes of these next generation
enzymes when you typically may come up
against them what that ultimately means
for your assay and what these key
attributes or enhanced attributes can do
to improve your assay
so let's start with specificity
and generally the challenges we have at
specificity is we have non-amp
non-specific amplification of a target
we didn't intend to identify or amplify
in the first place this comes from ms
prime dna and generally an enzyme that's
active at room temperature right
we're going to get that misprime dna
because we do want that benefit of
setting up our acid in temperature
so how do we get that benefit without
that misprimed amplification of a target
we didn't identify
and this is where leveraging hot start
enzymes enzymes that are not active at
room temperature while we're setting up
our assay leveraging those enzymes such
that even if we do get that misprimed
dna we don't detect that in a downstream
analysis right so these hot start
enzymes
are modified either through the addition
of an antibody chemical an acid body
molecule or aptomer rendering that
enzyme inactive at room temperature such
that when we are ready the assay is
complete
and ready for cycling we can raise the
temperature of that assay to 90 degrees
activate that enzyme and now under those
more stringent conditions we get the
annealing of our primers the template at
the right locations and that active
enzyme now is focused on amplifying our
target of interest
so if we jump to the next slide
we have some examples right we look at
example a on the left hand side
if we don't have a hot start enzyme when
we're setting up that reaction we're
getting that miss prime target or
misprime targets and we're seeing the
results and amplification of that active
enzyme because it's active at that room
temperature setup in this particular
example
we leverage that hot start enzyme we
follow the same setup process but now
that enzyme is only active when we're
ready
and then through that we see that
expected amplification and the resultant
of higher yield of that particular
target of interest
and if we jump over to example b
this is highlighting the fact that
through
leveraging higher cycling temperatures
we get greater specificity with these
thermostable enzymes
and as a result it we get a higher yield
and specific amplification of our target
of interest
but now let's jump to processivity
and processivity refers to how many
nucleotides are being incorporated
within a single binding event our enzyme
binding to that template and generally
what prevents that enzyme from from
integrating
several or many on the higher end
nucleotides in one binding event is the
presence of inhibitors for example right
they knock that enzyme or distract that
enzyme from being able to incorporate
many nucleotides and knock the enzyme
off the template so the resultant of
that is shorter amplicons or cdna
and we get low processivity of this
enzyme because now more enzyme binding
events have to occur in order for us to
get a full length cdna
so
the best way to overcome this is to
leverage
enzymes that have inhibitor tolerance
and through that they're able to
incorporate they can withstand the
presence of those inhibitors and
incorporate many nucleotides at the same
time or the same binding of that and
ultimately that means improved
processing power
which ultimately will mean for your
assay
full length amplicons
and here's a great example so if you
look at example a
in each of these columns
we have
a designation h which represents a high
processivity enzyme l1 l2 l3 and l4
represent low processivity enzymes so if
we focus on the first pair of columns we
can see
our high process of the enzyme
in the presence of no inhibitor and the
banding pattern that we would expect and
the same for the low processivity enzyme
l1 and l2 as soon as we start to
introduce formalin an inhibitor we see
the banding pattern of those low
processivity enzymes start to drop off
right but consistent for our high
processivity enzyme those that are
tolerant of let's say in this case
formula
in the second set of columns
and that grouping of four very similar
concept right and the left hand side of
each of those columns we have our high
processing the enzyme and the expected
band pattern
and l3 and l4 low processivity enzymes
and the introduction in the second third
and fourth columns
inhibitors that are all ultimately
altering the banding pattern which
dictate those enzymes are intolerant and
are incapable of amplifying a specific
target
when those inhibitors are present
if we jump to example b
there's a numerical representation of
that data right that
transcriptional efficiency that we can
see with high processivity enzymes
versus those low processivity enzymes
that are denoted in those blue bars
so thermal stability
right the lower the temperature that
we're doing our amplification stages at
the greater the likelihood of will come
across or our enzyme will come across
secondary structures
resulting in truncated synthesis right
and this is either due to
secondary and or high gc content
so the best way to resolve this is to
increase that temperature at which we're
doing this reaction or this reaction is
being conducted and that requires an
enzyme that's tolerant and is able to
perform
accurately and efficiently at higher
temperatures
or also known as a thermostable enzyme
right so if we look at that image just
down the center of the screen
37 degrees we have this high presence of
these secondary structures which
ultimately will result in truncated
synthesis
but if we can run that same reaction
with the thermostable enzyme at 55 to 65
degrees
we see that nice clean single strand and
that enzyme is able to run along
uninhibited
and that's what the data
or the gel image on the far right hand
side is indicating right we can run that
reaction with a thermal stable enzyme
whether at 50 degrees all the way
through 65 and we get that nice
consistent banning pattern
so now we're going to jump to accuracy
and the
application of particular relevance
let's say would be sequencing and in
this particular area we want to maintain
the integrity of the sequence that we
are ultimately amplifying and detecting
so here we're going to want to leverage
high fidelity enzymes with extremely low
error rates right and if you look at our
benchmark enzyme platinum superfly 2
in comparison to those that are offered
by our industry peers
you can expect up to 350 times
the accuracy
as compared to the conventional
dna polymerase
and last but not least greater speed
right so
we want to avoid
the length of time that's required let's
say in a longer essay how do we start to
improve that improve that turnaround
time so we're not waiting an hour and
potentially maybe we can get to 20
minutes
right
and in the the example on the right hand
side
we can see again a flagship enzyme our
platinum two
back hot star dna polymerase
we compare that to our industry peers
through ramping time they're fairly
similar right but where you really start
to see that advantage is through that
cycling time
and through the course of those multiple
cycles you are now starting to cut down
the length of time the total time it
takes for you to complete that assay and
using an enzyme like this you can
achieve up to four times faster
synthesis than conventional tac dna
polymerase
how do you know what enzyme to leverage
right there
we have next generation enzymes that
possess
some or potentially all of these
qualities
but to
to leverage an enzyme that possesses all
of these qualities
it can become
cost prohibitive right
so it's really critical that you
understand when we go back to that
workflow
what are the attributes or
characteristics of your sample input
type
and potentially your target
and your downstream analysis
such that
you can identify what challenges you may
come up against and which key features
you need to ensure that are built into
your enzyme so that this way
whether you choose an enzyme with let's
say all five key attributes or you
select an enzyme that has two or three
enzymes two or three of those key
features
you'll still ultimately get the same
output at a much more cost it'll it'll
be much more cost effective right and
that's what's really critical and just
as a quick comment here
generally
customers are quite curious about you
know when do i get my thermo fisher
support team to engage in my process to
help me kind of navigate which will be
which enzymes or components become the
best fit for me
and the answer overwhelming it
overwhelmingly is it's never too early
right the earlier we partner the earlier
we start to have those conversations and
you engage our technical and r d teams
the earlier they can advise on what
components would best suit your
particular assay of interest
such that you get off the ground much
quicker ultimately saving you time space
and money
so if you look at
protein design
and the development of this next
generation enzymes it comes from two
different sides we have the protein
design side
where
we can leverage things like rational
design site-specific mutagenesis as an
example protein fusion technology
we can
leverage protein evolution it's directed
to have to push the enzyme to develop a
specific phenotype or characteristic
or we can go to
natural sources of biodiversity those
atypical climates
find enzymes that perform under unique
conditions
on the flip side of that our enzymes
come with a wide variety of buffers
and that chemistry is a joint chemistry
approach can we tweak that buffer to
optimize the activity of that enzyme and
if we take it a step further
and certainly as the market evolves for
how do we develop let's say enzyme that
is capable of being
you know stable or good at room
temperature or creates lighter
transportation costs or can be used in
the field and this is where we start
talking about buffer formulations that
have no glycerol right and we talked
about those lyo ready products or lyell
ready and bonds
so if we go back again to the protein
side of developing these next generation
enzymes
we can go to natural sources and this is
driven more by luck right we go to a
unique climate and we spontaneously
identify an enzyme but we didn't
anticipate to identify or know we were
looking for
and we find something that's naturally
occurring right that's one side of it
then we can take control and and maybe
pivot into rational design based on our
understanding of what that enzyme looks
like from a structural perspective
how do we start to tweak that structure
by altering the amino acid composition
right and ultimately to improve the
activity of that and then we change the
phenotype of that enzyme
and then finally protein evolution can
we not so much by luck but direct
phenotype that potentially an enzyme
will ultimately take on right can we put
it into a high stress high temperature
situation let's say as an example in
order to develop an enzyme that is
capable of performing
reactions at higher temperatures like
those thermostable enzymes that i
mentioned earlier
so here's an example of that directed
evolution driving that enzyme to have a
particular phenotype by mutating
existing enzymes and the example here or
the the method here being highlighted is
compartmentalized self-replication
where we leverage e coli
and we have a dna polymerase encoded
gene which is being self-replicated
under a stressful condition in this
particular case let's say
it's a highly stressful high temperature
environment right ultimately can we
drive
at e coli to self-replicate the dna
polymerase
at a high temperature create that stress
such that we only get
mutated dna polymerase that is able able
to perform
that process
at a high temperature right ultimately
can we pull that clone out and then
leverage it to develop a next generation
enzyme that is highly thermal stable
another example being the enzyme fusion
technology right so we see this in high
fidelity the dna polymerase again that
would be very relevant for sequencing
in this particular case
we have combined a
a traditional dna polymerase
infuse that with a
proofreading enzyme
similar to something that we would see
in a pfu dna polymerase which ultimately
creates improved processivity
it enhances the enzyme's ability to
process that template ultimately making
it faster and so that's the features
that we're calling it at the bottom
right we improve that reaction speed and
increase the accuracy and fidelity of
that enzyme by creating this fusion
protein
so when we talk about advances in enzyme
development it's a combination or it's a
multi-pronged approach
protein evolution
buffer innovation direct immunogenesis
and through leveraging this
multi-pronged approach we've developed
some of our most recent cutting edge
flagship enzymes which includes platinum
two attack hot start dna polymerase
superscript four
first transcriptase
and platinum super phi 2 or high
fidelity
dna polymerase all backed by 40 years of
experience
in enzyme development and manufacturing
now that we've talked a little bit about
some of these next generation enzymes
and how they're developed let's look at
some examples that you can start
leveraging today starting with
platinum 2 dna polymerase
this particular enzyme possesses hot
start technology and what that means for
you as an end user is it comes with
heightened sensitivity and specificity
meaning greater yield of your target at
target amplicon
the enzyme is activityless at room
temperature
attributing to its ease of use for room
temperature setup and because of this
specificity sensitivity and ease of use
from a setup perspective at room
temperature you're getting this
reproducibility between your reactions
and all of that is achieved through the
antibodies that are bound to the enzyme
rendering it activityless at room
temperature until we do that initial
denaturation step where we separate that
antibody from that enzyme bringing it to
an active state and if we look at the
examples in the bottom right hand corner
regardless of how much template we
introduce into our reaction
we still get this nice crisp banding
across the board and when we look at
in the in the last image in the bottom
right hand corner under column p what
this is representing is at the zero hour
time mark when we set up our reaction at
room temperature and we run that
reaction subsequently we get a nice
crisp band
if we keep that set up for 24 hours at
room temperature we still get a nice
crisp band but when we look at enzymes
that don't possess hot start technology
and we set up that reaction and run
immediately we already start to see some
of that drop-off in our in our target
anti-con and it's even more so when we
hold that reaction at temperatures at
room temperature for 24 hours and run
that reaction
displayed on your screen is our first
poll question
which area do you experience challenges
with assay development
dna rna extraction
amplification related
detection related
others
we look at next generation enzyme
development
if you'll remember earlier we discussed
it happens
on two sides
by tweaking the enzyme itself from a
structural perspective but also that
buffer chemistry that comes along with
that enzyme
and in this particular instance by
tweaking the buffer that comes with
platinum two dna polymerase
we can start to improve the speed four
times faster than a conventional tac dna
polymerase
we can start to
elevate the enzyme's ability to tolerate
inhibitors
and we can also elevate the enzyme's
ability to amplify difficult and gc rich
targets
and all of this attributes to
time to results improved ease of use and
versatility so if i can draw your
attention to the bottom right hand
corner of this of this slide and if you
look at the gels again we can see that
whether inhibitors are present or not
present that enzyme is able to
accurately amplify our target amplicon
with a nice crisp band
and if we look at the bottom right hand
corner that last image
and from the left side of that last
image
we have 29 gc content and on the far
right hand side
77 gc content
regardless
we are seeing nice crisp consistent
banding indicating that this indicating
that this enzyme is able to perform an
accurate amplification even in even in
gt-rich targets
displayed on your screen is our second
poll question
would you be would you like to be
contacted by our business development
manager to help you make a purchase
yes or no
so if we look at now a reverse
transcriptase and the flagship enzyme
being superscript 4
known for its high sensitivity and
robustness
this particular enzyme
can reduce ct values by as much as eight
cycles when we talk about rtq pcr
it has the added benefit of high
tolerance to inhibitors in sample and
it's super fast right 10 minutes to
reaction time
the key attributes are elevated
attributes sensitivity reproducibility
time to results ease of use and
versatility
and the image i'd like to call out on
the far right hand corner we can see
superscript 3 and superscript 4
have this nice
consistent banding pattern actually
between each other when we look at some
enzymes rts from our industry peers in
columns p n t and q
we start to see some of these bands
missing and when we compare both
superscripts superscript 3 and
superscript 4 we can see that
improvement in this next generation
iteration from superscript 3 being
superscript 4.
displayed on your screen is our third
poll question
would you like to receive a quote at an
early stage of your research yes or no
if we switch gears for a moment and
start to look at
innovations in buffer and buffer
chemistry
and how we can start to tweak this
chemistry for the benefit of some of our
more complex assays
as in this case multiplexing
how are the advancements in buffer
chemistry ultimately helping us to
create and achieve optimal result
results with some of these trickier
assays if you will
and in this instance when you're dealing
with multiple prime repairs one of the
biggest challenges is going to be
how can you quickly calculate
what that optimal annealing temperature
needs to be for your prime repairs so
that you're able to amplify your targets
without compromise
and as we can see here
by tweaking that buffer chemistry
and in this instance developing a buffer
that is capable of enabling all of our
prime repairs to universally anneal at a
temperature of 60 degrees celsius
without sacrificing
the amplification of any one of our
given targets
now we are starting to
elevate the performance of our enzymes
and our reactions through ease of use
again specificity multiplexing and
versatility and that's what that image
is showing you on the bottom right hand
corner right across the board for each
of our target amplicons all of them are
being amplified nice crisp and clear
without compromise
so again
and i think the key here is focusing
maybe on the bottom half of this screen
right again the topic being multiplexing
and when we look at a variety of
infectious targets
whether viral and bacterial which come
with their own nuances and if we look
maybe even specifically within bacterial
gram-positive and gram-negative both
with their own nuances and as we go
along
how do we
leverage buffer chemistry and treat that
buffer chemistry such that we can look
at these variety of targets with their
own nuances and still get
nice specific amplification and that's
what that gel is showing you on the
right hand side right whether we have
one target we introduce two and we jump
all the way to 15
all of those bands stay consistent
across the board
if we take buffer chemistry one step
further and start to talk about some of
these more recent market trends maybe
past 12 or 18 months or so point-of-care
diagnostics leveraging assays and
cartridges
but even how do we eliminate cold
transport or cold storage or extend
shelf life this is where lyophilization
compatible assays and as an extension
lyophilization compatible enzymes come
into play
and existing buffers contain glycerol
which makes them incompatible with
biophilization so can we develop buffer
and buffer chemistries that don't
possess glycerol without compromising
the performance of our enzymes
and we offer these wire ready
options for our reverse transcriptases
our polymerases our master mixes as well
as our pcr enhancers like ribolock
inhibitor
so in this second last section we'll
start to see some of these next
generation enzymes in action
let's start with rtqpcr so in this
particular assay
this group wanted to develop
an assay that could be leveraged in a
microfluidic based cartridge
and right off the bat what that demands
is by optimization compatible components
we may be dealing with sample input
types that are
that have inhibitors that are present
right we're dealing with saliva
potentially blood samples
which also comes with potentially low
target
in our sample and if it's going to be
something that's leveraging a cartridge
potentially at point of care
airports stadiums we're going to need
something quite fast
so in this example we have two targets
in this duplex reaction
para influenza and coronavirus
and we can see that by pairing
platinum two
attack hot start dna polymerase in a
lyophilization compatible format
and
in vitrogen's
superscript one step rtq pcr reverse
transcriptase also in a lyophilization
compatible format we see that we can get
great amplification and detection of
both of our targets without compromise
and when we compare that with some of
the options that are available on the
market from some of our industry peers
the performance
is head and shoulders above
right demonstrating fast highly
efficient and robust amplification of
our viral rna targets
in our second example
this particular group was leveraging
a crispr fluorescence detection system
in order to detect the presence of their
target
through a qualitative amplification
right so in this case and very popular
for point of care settings so in this
particular instance again point of care
we're looking at tricky samples right
with potentially inhibitors saliva and
blood we're going to need something
that's inhibitor tolerant superscript 4
is the standout choice
and because of the specificity that is
required for our guide rna and cas12a
complex
partnered with that fluorescent probe
the specificity that is required for
that complex to detect that target of
interest
we're going to need a high fidelity
enzyme a proof leading enzyme and in
this case the flagship enzyme being
platinum super phi 2 dna polymerase
right to preserve that sequence such
that we get accurate detection cleavage
of our pro and subsequent detection
all of which in a live ready format so
that it can be leveraged in a point of
care setting
in this third example
another really hot topic right
isothermal amplification
very similar concept
great for utility in the field for point
of care settings
again we're going to be dealing with
potentially trickier samples
inhibitors
superscript 4 rt will be the enzyme of
choice
and leveraging an isothermal enzyme in
this case a bsm dna polymers
create all of which in a lie ready
format
in our last example
variant sequencing for stars coke ii
lots of activity in this area as well
so again
we're going to be leveraging superscript
4 rt
kind of overcome any of those initial
challenges that we have with our sample
input type
but then again the focus being we need
to preserve
the integrity of those sequences
across our samples
using a high fidelity proofreading
enzyme in this case
platinum 2 superfly 2 being the enzyme
of choice
very fast highly efficient and robust
amplification of our target
in our last section we'll talk a little
bit about the quality and manufacturing
capabilities of thermo fisher scientific
all of which can be leveraged by our
customers so that they do not have to
invest in those infrastructure
themselves so if you look at your
journey
from
starting on the bench all the way
through to
getting onto the market
you're going to have this feasibility
and developmental stage and this is
where engaging your thermal fissure team
is going to be really critical the
commercial team the rnd team
the technical teams
these teams will guide you and advise
you on
based on the parameters of your assay
and your long-term goal to getting onto
market they'll advise you on what
components really
make the most sense or which ones are
worth kind of streamlining your focus on
right so it'll accelerate your time in
this phase
that'll help you get to verification
much quicker to get that design lock in
place
and now you can start to think about
what do i need from a supply chain
perspective right are the existing
formats that i'm sourcing with a catalog
sufficient or are there alternate
formats that i could use that are more
conducive for my manufacturing or my
commercial service
right and all of that setup is going to
come in handy when you enter the
regulatory phase and eventually
when you hit the market
so this is an image of our
site in vilnius lithuania it is our
center of excellence for enzymology over
40 years of experience in enzyme
development and it's supported by over
1400 colleagues of ours
the facility possesses
all of the regulatory standards needed
for the production of these components
and namely i'd call out iso 9001 and iso
13485
among a few others
and here's just a nice table indicating
when these certifications were first
granted and registered and that they're
regularly kept up to date
when we talk about product delivery and
delivering the best product
for your business for your assay
we can start to look at our kits
and
customize those existing kits adding
components dropping components we can
even develop kits that don't exist at
all
right totally custom kits
we can break down these kits such that
we offer standalone components
and we can even take all of that a step
further by tweaking
the format the chemistry right whether
it's size
or the chemistry from a ly already
perspective
and potentially even dna-free iterations
of these components for those highly
sensitive assays
all of which is not totally inclusive
but are fair examples of how we can
tweak these components to better fit
your needs
altogether when we talk about thermo
fisher scientific as your partner in
molecular assay development
leverage the businesses experience to
accelerate the time spent in those early
developmental stages
take advantage of that wide breadth and
depth of components that are offered
through the portfolio
take it a step further
with integrated and customized solutions
that best fit your business and
commercial service or product
and last but not least
using cutting-edge components
such that the technology you develop
stays on the bleeding edge
and throughout this entire process
working with your business development
manager
to keep that process from start to
finish seamless
that you can focus on your success
i'll pause there and open it up for some
questions
thank you naeem for your informative
presentation we will now start the q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
great presentation and thank you i have
been designing an
rtqpcr assay using template from culture
cells and we'll start
testing blood samples
should i redesign my assay since the
quality of the template may be subpar
great question i'm glad you enjoyed the
webinar
as i mentioned in the presentation
blood samples may contain components
such as hemen that could reduce the
sensitivity of your rtqpcr assay i'd
recommend choosing sample preparation
methods specifically designed for blood
samples and for the rtq-pcr assay i'd
recommend using superscript 4 reverse
transcriptase and platinum 2 tac dna
polymerase
both of these enzymes are highly
tolerant of inhibitors
in case the sample preparation was not
as robust
all right thank you our next question i
have developed a rtq pcr
master mix using superscript reverse
transcriptase and platinum tac dna
polymerase can i lyophilize this master
mix
or do i need to use lyell ready enzymes
mentioned in your presentation
another great question so in the case of
both of these enzymes the buffer
contains glycerol
and unfortunately the pla the presence
of that glycerol is ultimately what
makes
these particular enzymes and the buffers
incompatible with lyophilization so
you'll need to remove the glycerol from
the master mix which is extremely
difficult
but the good news is
both of these enzymes come in a format
that is lyophilization compatible
both superscript rt and the platinum tag
dna polymerase and you can expect to get
similar performance in using the liar
ready format with little optimization
thank you naive we have time for one
more question
thank you for your talk i like the idea
of eliminating the sample preparation
step especially when i am starting with
a low amount of template
in
cerebrospinal excuse me cerebrospinal
fluid which enzymes do you recommend for
real-time pcr assay and do you have
samples that i can test
you're absolutely welcome and thank you
so much for attending if you're planning
to minimize the sample prep step
then i would highly recommend using
enzymes with high sensitivity again such
as platinum two-tac dna polymerase
if you're starting with an rna target
then certainly i'd suggest including
superscript 4 reverse transcriptase both
of these enzymes have the highest
sensitivity
highly tolerant of inhibitors with the
added benefit of speed
we can certainly offer you some samples
to test both in glycerol or lyo ready
formats
for more information or requesting for
samples please go to thermofisher.com
forward slash oem enzymes
thank you nayem for your informative
presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event thank you and goodbye for
now
you